hello everybody welcome to another
episode of riffing with Griffon I'm once
again back at the all things comedy
studio and I want to thank everybody for
listening and all your comments and all
your reviews and everything you know and
I really appreciate the support on once
again I want to start the episode off by
introducing one of my favorite people in
the world that's why I love doing this
podcast got to get to sit down with
these people and let you get to know
them but welcome to the podcast the
funny talented passionate compassionate
Tiffany Haddish everybody in the house
now I'm not sure you probably too busy
to be what to watching my podcast but
what I have on the podcast is I do
different theme songs like I always say
I'm looking for a new theme song I can
do this there we go I'm looking for a
new theme song and so I started to get
copyright problems because I was singing
like you know regular songs and adding
riffing with Griffin and then these
great artists out here in the world
started sending in theme songs so here's
another great theme song from mattock
productions special for this special
episode with Tiffany Haddish and we you
might see us
got some flows on here too you never
know
[Music]
[Music]
for me and I'm in the building hanging
with my boy every Kristen week we're
gonna talk about things that's going on
I don't know but I know I got a flow
today I'm okay first of all the very
talented ultra talented given II had a
she was here I don't even know it's like
that um well thanks for coming well
thank you for having me
I mean for you to have such a busy
schedule and for you to come in because
I know that you being on here is a
bigger favor for me that it is for you
[Laughter]
right off the top so I mean I've known
you for so long I know we go back to
like doing open mics and just being at
the Laugh Factory and doing all that
kind of stuff but like what is like what
what's the thing that you didn't know is
that being this famous was gonna be like
they would like like we dream for it we
want it but then we wouldn't boom it
happened what was the thing you were
like oh I don't know I don't really want
to be famous I just wanted to be
successful at doing stand-up and I
didn't realize like well what I said
want to get more money doing stand-up
thing you got to get on TV okay get on
TV in there so you taking all these
acting classes and all that Stephanie
like okay this is fun but I would say
the thing that I didn't like I didn't
realize it would get this big I wasn't
really expecting it to get this big and
the thing that I think is most difficult
is just trusting people
making sure that you're surrounded by
people that you can actually trust that
actually care about you and then it's
like when you try to implement that the
oldest person I've known them for years
they take care and they realize they
really don't well you know it's funny
you say that because I was really moved
by how mad Kevin Hart was on the on the
on that radio interview like I've never
seen him like that he was like going in
he didn't even let you talk I was like
damn so you mean you do you there are
some people in your life they go back in
the beginning and right I mean in a well
you know it's like other comics is great
like those people cuz they'd understand
the struggle if you understand how
difficult it is and they like and they
talk and mess or maybe they had it and
they lost it and they're talking
messages just to me it's like you know I
really appreciate the people that love
and care for me and I try my best to
support and love and care for them as
well and you know but there's some
people you just you think they really
had you I don't we known each other
since we were little kids so you think
like oh you got my back and then you
find out they sell you out so yeah yeah
you know what I could tell how how hard
it is I could see it on your face I mean
I know I mean that's like you want to be
able to trust everybody but even without
Fame even without that entertainment
business you realize oh they're actually
there's people like this in your life
anyway regardless yeah everybody has
their own agenda like the main thing you
gotta remember is everyone thinks of
themselves first and then maybe they
think about you somewhere in now and it
makes me always it's me first okay so
how would someone get to know you then
like now like what would the process be
like how would it take a very long time
you know getting on me yeah so you got
you know how you'd have the 90-day rule
like you know so like dude you would you
have a 90-day rule for friendship - oh
no I don't let a lot of new people in I
have so many I have so many already I
already got so many already so to let
someone in I would have they would have
to see to me be something special right
now
yeah
same ticket yeah and just like cuz I
could see through the [ __ ] man
I could see like my rack is smelly I see
it's like I could taste it like I can't
I can see it so it's like well it's nice
to meet you
hey no but that's like a comic thing
though you know how you can look out at
the crowd and you can kind of see like
oh this chicks having a bad day maybe
they look like they bout to get divorced
or this looks like like I can always
tell like if I see a couple that's a
little bit older and I go you guys marry
and they go no I go oh this is you've
been married before
yeah it's that kind of thing so it's
like I guess it's like that's how we are
with people that I mean but like I won't
associate like I know I'm on some new
like for 2019 I'm only I'm honoring my
feelings right and I'm like 110 percent
I'm not gonna doubt my feelings and I'm
gonna tell you how I feel immediately
I'm trying to figure out the most
professional way to do it but I'm gonna
let you know how I feel about something
and whether that be me speaking on it or
not saying anything at all and like
giving you a look like like I don't want
no broke friends I don't want to
associate with broke people
I think it's contagious and broke people
are usually desperate you know I think
what you really mean is people not
working hard because sometimes people
are struggling to try to make it but but
they're doing something in the process I
don't like people around me they're just
like hmm they're just happy with their
life like I'm not gonna try to do
anything more this is it I don't mind
that that I don't I don't mind people
that's happy with where they are in life
that's me that's actually satisfying
okay but broke people and I'm not saying
just necessarily financially broke I'm
talking broke people like spiritually
broke or emotionally broke and they try
to rob you of all your stuff you know
I'm saying like they kind of energy
vampires yeah yeah yeah yeah cool Anya
yeah I want people rich I'm on rich
people around me and when I say rich I
don't mean just money I mean rich in
spirit rich in personality you know in
kindness and compassion like rich that
way
I don't want broke people around I
totally I totally is always being
miserable and negative yeah I can't be I
could be right but if it's a mess I
gotta go cause you bought the steel for
me yeah yeah yeah
yeah then and then when they stealing
from you they mad at you about it movie
comedy shows you don't like people that
put little affront anything that you've
done well okay gotta go
you know what I remember I remember I
went to Houston I was in I was the
Houston is but whatever club it was and
one of the openers I know no you know
and he said he said oh you the headliner
you know I think I've seen one your
little videos online but it's like it's
like you know what I hate about calm at
this comedy business is that it's one of
the few businesses that you have to
prove yourself like from scratch every
single time every time they make you
feel like that like it's like if you
were like a if you're a heart surgeon at
at one Hospital they're not gonna make
you be a nurse at the other one they
gonna be like oh you said your heart
surgeon so that means you know what
you're doing and boom boom boom no in
the comedy it's like every club you go
to every gig day they make you feel like
have you done this before yeah 17
specialist yeah selling out theaters so
how long have you been doing about you
know can you send us a tape you want to
do it you want to just walk onstage well
it hasn't been like that for me lately
yeah because you broke through yeah last
year it was kind of like in a year
before even after girls trip came out
like oh you want to go up yeah I'm in a
movie girl [ __ ] what is what is that
yeah who were you in that was that like
good that was that like do you not
beseech the thing is like I know you so
you've been doing a lot of things you've
been in a lot of things for a long time
for a long time yes because I'm fury
ating like she got her big break like
you know like they sell you at a
Starbucks get mad about it like yeah you
see she stole a movie and this is their
big business finally you made it I get
why does
it'll be new on the scene I'm like I've
been here a lot I know everybody's like
yeah just cuz I don't know you mister
reporter man doesn't mean I don't I what
excuse me I know I said now you had like
you almost at 1 name status just Haddish
really yeah yeah everybody to see they
like Tiffany Haddish to me other I know
but if they if you if they say that name
people know they people know there's no
other there's no other Haddish you know
what's so cool about that is like when I
was a little kid I used to try to find
my dad right and I couldn't find my and
I was searched all these searches and
stuff and I had came to the conclusion
that I was an only Haddish in all of
America not only had she not of America
this is why I got this name Tiffany
Haddish so then nobody can say they me
or related to me or anything and then I
found my dad my dad came in like oh wait
no I'm not the only one and there's no
other would you go look at you went
looking you wanted to find your - yeah
it's a funny time I started looking for
him when I was 16 oh yeah and I couldn't
find him
I guess I wasn't looking in the right
places well I mean it's different now in
terms of technology I mean back in
unknown in 1900 method she was like
other than hundred you know it's funny
you say that cuz I just go went to go
visit my mom in Spain you know cuz I my
parents my mom and my stepdad they moved
to Spain mm-hmm like three years ago cuz
the cost of living is so low but she
just randomly she's kind of losing her
memory a little bit so she started
talking about my dad for the first time
like really talking about him and I was
like oh [ __ ] this is like do I wanna do
you want to know do I want to know about
that no it was it was weird because when
I was a kid she told me his name but I
had forgot it and that told me like oh
maybe it wasn't that important but at
the time I remember saying to her I was
like oh I just want to know something
about my dad because like you know his
diabetes run in the family but I got to
worry about you know and she was just
like I raised you you know now and she
was so like big about it that I was like
okay maybe this because I know people
got their own story you know and I know
that things happen with women that they
they had their own story their own path
that maybe she didn't want him in my
life and I don't I don't have any
grudges about it but didn't when I
recently when I went back as she was
telling me his name and stuff and I
thought well maybe it's time for me to
like check in on this you should
you know so I don't even know how to
start Oh first thing go Facebook then
like people find her yeah but at this
point right now my my dad would probably
be 90 years old you know what I mean oh
he was older than him I yeah yeah my mom
was probably 30 she was 30 when she had
me so he was probably like out you know
well my mom was a looker I saw that I
don't know if my 80 plus year old dad is
gonna be on Facebook at this point he
might be you know you know it's funny
I'm I have siblings that I think I do
that's the thing what I'm saying you
know so I'm trying to figure that that's
something I won't look like it just
start where were you were born yeah I
guess so I was born in LA I guess I
guess it's time for me look at me
getting our person that's what I do in
my name on your birth certificate no I
don't know no she didn't put anybody no
no that's not and I get why women do
that too though that's like a thing if
you're a single mom and you like either
either you're gonna put him on there so
you could be like oh well he gonna marry
I think I think I am on a fair baby what
if it's one of her friends yeah man if
it was her friend
it'd be all traumatic but I might look
into doing it one thing I like about you
you are see people don't know this about
you but you very you business orientated
you're like I'm gonna do this justice
and this you looking up tax code you
trying to find you trying to beat the
system
if you are you know I'm not trying to
beat the system but I'm trying to learn
how to use the system to my advantage
yes you are and I think we could all
learn from that you know cuz I remember
that I remember you also he was always
talking about that thing about like
there's so what was that thing it was
like a tax law that you can like not pay
your taxes or you can like well yeah we
give money for your car I was like you
oh you don't notice we use on the phone
and I was like okay it's only you
interrupt and know how to not pay so
much in taxes it makes me mad I wish the
IRS will send me like a birthday card
right yeah thank you know they can feel
better about paying it but yeah there's
like like it's like there when you're
just a citizen
you're actually not required as a
citizen but because the way your name is
ring on your birth certificate like your
entity and like businesses are like it's
crazy yeah y'all gotta look like the
straw man stuff and like you know like
you can have your own country basically
in your house if you own the house like
yeah like you could be considered an
illegal immigrant once you walk out your
door really but like as soon as you're
born like your net the way because if
you look at your birth certificate your
name isn't all capital letters and it's
not supposed to be written like that
when you're a person when you're a
person supposed to be uppercase and
lowercase letters but when it's all
capital letters that means your entity a
business a corporation right so then and
then like you're like an investment so
like you're so secure your social
security number and the number that's on
your birth certificate it's like on a
stock market and I'm making money off of
that
like it goes back to Roosevelt guys we
got to look into this yeah guys you got
to get when you win you when you watch
this you need to go online and look this
stuff up ya know probably gonna get
audited extra payment like so you
started doing comedy at you know doing
the comedy camp everybody know your
story already you're 15 you're in yeah
you're the group home yeah that's
different you want two different things
in did you always feel like comedy saved
you
guaranteed it's like me it saves me
today like sometimes I might have a bad
situation on stage New Year's but it's
still not it's not the worst I mean I
might not have been normal Tiffany
higher status but it wasn't like the
worst show I've ever had oh of course
and I still felt good about it I mean
she had a New Year's show in Miami it
was probably like a hundred dollars a
ticket which is probably what the people
were upset about and that's all that it
that's all that it really is people made
bad choices for New Year's because first
of all going to economy show is not a
good New Year's thing okay not lazy and
you don't want to be there you mad that
you like didn't have other plans and you
like okay let's go to this
and then it doesn't live up to your
expectation I don't care who it is
everybody I know I had a bad New Year
show this this past New Year's so I just
got off a plane from seeing my parents
right tired tired and you can see these
people are like no you know
yo cuz the person I really want to hang
out we didn't let the party there's
nothing going on so they decide to go to
this comedy show so you had a rough one
yeah it was a rough show and it was like
and I think it's my fault though it's my
fault
cuz normally it wouldn't matter but I
got like so uncomfortable with like cuz
I've been working on this set for like a
whole year and I'm not used to seeing a
lot of cell phones I'm just not used to
oh right right and I came out and it was
like 4,000 seat theater and it was like
two or three thousand cell phones like I
was more lit from the phone and I work
from the actual stage like and it made
me a little uncomfortable and so in that
discomfort I just kind of like let
everything go and I was tired I was
exhausted because you're working on a
special right and this was gonna be the
material and you didn't want necessarily
4,000 YouTube accounts we're having your
special online exactly and because it's
like that's my I penis you know I'm your
property right and what's this out there
online then it's like it's gone and it's
like if I do it in my specialty like oh
that's I've seen that already she did
that already from day seven what Lydia
is much better now the quality looks
better but I know that joke she's still
doing that same joke right right you
know and it's like as a comedian I don't
know what why is that like as a comedian
you can't like you could do the same
joke over and over in different cities
but or for different audiences but then
if people seen it before whatever
they're like oh you did that already are
you doing the same it's not like music
you want to hear like you want to hear
how an artist go like oh you say my
favorite song right you know but they
don't want to be like do my favorite
joke but sometimes they do that
something you're real fans like they'll
do it like wasn't like they were doing
it like they were like Roscoe what's
going on with Roscoe Roscoe right now
but at that point I had already just
kind of gave up and and that's my bad
not feel bad about that are you gonna do
you think that if you had to do it again
you'd be like okay that we got to take
people's cell phones or put them in
those bags that I would have liked
definitely hadn't put them in bags like
I didn't realize that was that pop
that's what I also realize how famous I
was yeah yeah yeah I had no idea was
that famous wherever I was like ha let
me get this Chloe well you know I had a
situation one time when I was I just I
was in Kentucky it just little Club and
like I'm I got the landing gear out I'm
about to land and like be done with the
show and this lady in the front row
she's sitting by herself and she starts
in you know she's got too much worse so
I pulled out my phone cuz I wanted to
record her that was a mistake because
that meant everybody went okay it's okay
to record now so in the middle of it she
tries to hit the phone out of my hand
okay but from the back from people's
cell phones it looks like she hit me oh
so of course
TMZ hit me uh Eric we're going with this
story about how this heckler hit you and
I was like man and I didn't want to send
them my video because they were the
scene I was like now I'm not gonna keep
this going but I thought to myself man
this is what we have to deal with now
how technology has made it so now you
know now it's like either we're gonna
have to like key right new jokes or we
got to be like yo you got to have a rule
that you can't record right you know and
exactly so like now since then like I've
been on stage probably 40 times since
then right now I'm into a naughty shows
and in local clubs and soon as I see
your cell phone I just stop yeah yeah I
know I won't even talk I'll just stand
there every be looking like like oh I
see a phone when the phone's gone I'll
continue to talk yeah I'm with you on
that I just did it again I just did a
show in Atlanta and in like this heckler
was acting up she was the couple was
drunk the whole table was drunk this
somebody pulls out their phone I go yeah
what are you doing he was like well
you're doing good right now and I was
like yo can't we just have a private
moment yeah okay this just keep our
private moment right now it's just have
this experience can we just have this
without it being like on your dumbass
Facebook page or whatever it is it's so
infuriating
right and then now we [ __ ] now we
got
yeah Matt now you think you're too good
to be on my Facebook page a lot for me
hey [ __ ] for me it's like alright you
know I get to like come see your Griffin
for free you know mean so I don't know
it does suck so I guess that's part of
the thing like again you realized how
ultra famous you are yeah I realize how
famous I was in did that just made me
love comedy even more like oh now I get
to it is it supposed to be a safe play
like for me it was it's always been a
safe place for me to express how I feel
and to get stuff off my chest and then
to actually find other people that feel
the same way yes I know what you mean I
I find it I find it therapeutic yeah you
know I find it like some stuffs going on
in my life and I literally go right to
the staging even if I'm doing jokes I've
done before I feel this different level
of emotion that I'm putting on it right
but what I've come to realize though is
that when you get cuz I'm not like I'm
not like ultra famous and I know my fame
I'm famous enough that I know that like
when I'm doing a particular type of show
I come out and I go oh I have to work
right now so I do flip into a mode I'm
like oh it's work time and I don't
necessarily like that uh-huh you know
when it's not fun like when you're
working you're like I'm working right
now I didn't get into this to work you
know to me but it's like I do understand
it and so freedom worked out but then
there's sometimes like I'm especially
from exhausted my soul be like I'll be
back here sleep goodnight I know what
I'm talking about then you go to that mo
you know exactly what joke you know
where your hands gonna do at that
particular joke and you just you just go
into it but then people come up to you
like oh my god you were so funny
you know and it's just like I know but
it's just like I have to remember that
just because I'm having a therapy
session right now they don't got to be a
part of it
exactly you gotta have fun what's the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
right before you've gone on stage I'll
tell you mine yeah sure
okay I was seeing this girl and we had
been fighting a little bit and literally
right before the guy is already saying
like copies of the stage next I get this
text I'm done with you I don't ever want
to see you again
grip it you know and I was like oh my
god like you know and I'm wondering I
want to rush through this because I was
like I didn't decide would you this what
happened you know what I mean but it was
like it was like one of those like I was
in another place we do it that's a great
way to describe it where your soul is
like okay I'm up yeah I'm working on
this right now yeah can you you've got
this can you handle this yeah that's
what happened to me hey it looks like
your soul tells your spirit hey spirit
I'm gonna leave you got this right just
make sure she doesn't die okay I'm going
on a quick 30-minute break I'm gonna
take a little lunch break I'll be back
tomorrow man have you had something like
that man my momma beat me up in the
Walmart parking lot before I went
onstage and I'll bet the lip and play
what yeah when you were kids or I was
like 23 she would are you oh my god I
mean if you read my book let's plug that
Tiffany Haddish shoes book what's the
name of your book again I got that last
black you know that's the last black
unicorn by Tiffany Haddish make sure you
guys pick that up I have information on
the video you can even if you don't read
you could get it on audiobook
I just got nominated for a Grammy for
that oh really yeah I don't even know
you could get nominated for a Grammy for
reading yeah
you're not just reading because when you
were reading you were putting in
flexions and you were like yeah but I
was just like wow like I remember when I
couldn't read and like my drama teacher
being like you gotta know how to read
it's important to do if you ever gonna
do anything like you got to know how to
it's important to do that so you had a
drama teacher you're talking about in
high school in high so you had a drama
teacher in high school and at the time
you couldn't read yeah I could barely
you barely read like three letter words
like I was reading on a second grade
level damn like I couldn't read
basically can read and then here you are
Here I am reading five scripts a week
audiobooks that's great United knows my
audiobooks you know how we both love
audio yes that's my thing yeah I love oh
me too I'm all about the audiobooks I
won't even listen to music in my car
unless somebody's in the car and then
let this happen to you people get in
your car and then the last audio book
something weird you don't need you know
that happens to be all the time so I'm
not I might I didn't know it was on
audiobook I meant to check almost imma
listen to that myself and your mom beats
you up in a Walmart parking lot and you
go on stage and I go on stage that night
did you talk about it yeah I had to you
had to I had to my lip was bursting my
eyes like messed up so and I talked
about it in people were laughing yeah
and it made me some mater started to cry
on stage oh that so yeah at the time you
didn't register that what you were going
through was a performance like you
didn't cause I I know exam ANSI this is
the same thing when I when I was like
coaching you know kids and like how many
can not even talk about when I used to
coach basketball and stuff like that and
then like I was a very animated coach
you know so I might be like you know
it's saying things to them I'm turning
around the crowds laughing you know and
I'm mad right it was the first time I
started to see that oh I'm I'm funny and
I don't matter the what the scenario
scenario is I'm just funny in these
scenarios right so that's what you
learned in that moment yes very hard and
I was like no guys this is a fun this is
not Chuck expressing my lip is busted
stop yeah just and then they're just
like oh she and she's dramatic this is
great where they just clapping for you
so I just walked out to stage everybody
start clapping the house was like what's
good and I'm like run into the bath and
crying there's like Rico some women come
in here they're like oh my god you were
amazing and then you realize your mom
beat you up every show
come on you can beat me up soon as you
get out the institution as you come with
my ass again
him you have I find do you have are you
experiencing a lot of hecklers or like
our people more respectful at your shows
are like when you do have hecklers what
you mean is it but how is it you're a
superstar female comedian is that come
with any other pressures is it like do
you feel uh you know especially with the
me to and everything that's going on
right now how are you how is this
affected you you think you think you've
made a difference you know me like in
terms of like changing it
since you're its SNL performance and all
that I don't think I mean I don't know
if I made a difference I never really
did you feel it did you I experienced to
me to moments I've had plenty of I mean
we're comedians in comedians are
perverts in slime balls a lot of them
are right here would you never came at
me crazy I've come at you I wanna
apologize I never touched
inappropriately thank you a beautiful
human it's gonna be in my book
Griffen EEP radish just a chick I know
you know riffin II know but I mean I've
experienced something still like I mean
we're guys say it's tough but it's like
I don't really acknowledge I don't give
it any energy and or I just shut it down
super fast I'll shut it down like so
yeah guys yeah nothing's it but that
Miami showdown I mean I was so obsessed
security just let these men just walk up
to the stage and like one of them look
like he was about to kill me like he
looked like a murderer and he just
walked up here like it but girl you know
you gonna be alright like no just like
what
thank you yes I've seen in The Bodyguard
where she was like that Club you know
dudes were like literally walking up to
the stage and I'm like [ __ ] I run [ __ ] I
just stand here am I gonna be I'm gonna
active right now I'm just gonna act
right right I'm gonna just be chillin
I'm gonna just be chill like I'm just
reach and I kept telling us I'll just be
chilled but you're like you're gonna be
okay you got like 4000 witnesses if
something happens you know one of my
exes sent that person up there to shoot
me in the head you know like what like
no okay well that's one says you don't
know cuz P I mean I read some of the
messages people write about me online
and some people hate my goods really
they hate everything about me
you can't even enjoy social media they
but they watching me
yeah right right they watching me so
they can continue to hate me so I'll be
like thank you so much for your support
thank you for going to see the movie
thank you for you know thank you for
taking the time out of your life to hate
me using your energy to promote me in
your own special kind of way thank you
like you have handled a lot of these
situations with grace and class you
really have well you should hear me when
I'm at home alone yeah it's like a
[ __ ] owe me you know like I say
that for like one second like I said I
said and then after that I'm like I must
have slept with her man probably just
having a bad day or asleep they they
wrote like three paragraphs by me you're
like I thought video somebody talked
about me for 25 minutes I got one of
those too I got a guy online that like I
saw my last special and then made a
whole video about it yeah I'm like what
that is so sweet
to me I was like that's all flattery you
are so sweet I wish you had your facts
right i'ma do some Corrections thank you
I like the videos I've seen a video
online
somebody did one before they said I saw
my soul to the devil and I'm a part of
the Illuminati
first off loominatee would never [ __ ]
with me cuz I tell everything
yeah yeah yeah I don't keep secrets if
you were brother luminaries a SWAT team
would have already came in here
you should write debug any hard drives
it like you know I got so everything so
it's like I don't keep secrets this is
part of the reason why people who
probably didn't take me all to wear like
it didn't take me to it because I don't
keep secrets I'm not a secret keeper
don't do no [ __ ] around me you don't
want the world today it keeps me out of
trouble that's true keep-keep sex stuff
away from me it's all I learned that at
an early age if everybody think I'll
tell on them they won't do dirt around
me oh that's true yeah okay all right I
might not get invited to the supercool
parties right right right you're not
gonna get to yeah you're not coming but
I don't want to be at that party if it's
just going on it's inappropriate I don't
want to be there you didn't so you
didn't go to the Will Smith sex party
like that you know I didn't get invited
today I want to ask you so a men always
hollering like I'm rose and stuff no you
feel like why not why do you think that
what did we think that's about because I
don't get it I think maybe because I
might they might think I'll tell on this
cuz they got [ __ ] already oh this
would be like intimidating for some
people they might think I'm super rich
and I'm not they might think I'm stuck
up right now they might think I'm out of
their famous to date now and that's okay
you today if you if you got the date up
if you got broke self esteem like that
yeah yeah you think you're not good
enough and get the [ __ ] out my face
because that's all you want it no matter
what he does he could be a truck driver
or whoever he may be coming Robert yeah
you can bet you proper right miss
Haddish I would like to you know some
sort of job yeah you know you do
something you create you do something in
some kind of way you have service to
others in some kind of way or you
creating some kind of income but you
don't need my money
yeah you know you don't need none of
that so you probably in the same
position because like you know there's
gonna be a lot of guys you might want to
date that you're just doing better than
theirs so what right that way you know
but I don't bring that I don't even
bring that up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but don't be trying to live off me too
that's my point I can feel the same way
like check this out I'll take
in Paris but I'm not paying your verizon
bill no you know what I mean that's you
right okay we gonna fly first class
right we gonna stay in a really nice
hotel right we gonna eat fancy and the
studio I'll pay for it
Time Warner Cable bill that's you that's
your boo yeah I'm with you on that bill
- ooh you're right that's you yeah
that's you matter of fact don't be
trying to stay at my house every damn
night guess what I don't stay in my
house every damn night now you not gonna
stay in my house every damn night you're
going to the bathroom it is like another
- Russian I feel like if you're gonna be
in my space you need to contribute to
the space being there so if the lawn
you know what's up with the lawn yeah
you can the grass you're picking the
Wiis on my garden you clean in my house
for me like would it why are you here
are you said that you can't enjoy your
house right now cuz you can't you're
always gone okay I guess that about it
yeah I cry a little bit I remember when
you got your house how excited you were
you like you don't understand about
y'all don't understand about tivities
she like she'll get to know the
neighborhood she would walk around and
see who's in the neighborhood if she
want to see are there any gay people
walking around yeah cuz that means it
that neighborhood is nice yeah it's
memory I'm like do you like were you
about to go I'm about to go soon friend
his house on my by elementary school
like what watch the police station late
West everything yeah you see the time
when she would call the cops just to see
what's the response but now you can't
even how you just always working what's
the what's next for you right now like
what yeah I know you're working on a
bunch of stuff well I got lay coming out
what's coming what's going on let's hear
about okay so lego movie two is about to
come out February 8th so I'm super
excited about that I just saw the movie
for the first time and it's actually
really good it's fun you say like you
didn't think it would like that wouldn't
be your thing I wasn't sure if it was if
it would be okay or let you know I
wasn't sure if I will fit in with that
that like group of people if I match
that but apparently I fit in alright
a very distinct voice so I'm not
surprised yeah and then but I am but I'm
I am really do you still so you're still
being shocked by the business yeah and
they have me like singing in the movie
and I was like oh you could sing don't
act like you can't sing well I likes to
sing I've been to karaoke with you know
if we turn some Tina Turner alright now
it's like I like to sing in like be
silly but to like actually like hear it
and they see it animated in all right
whoa
that's me and they didn't even tunes the
hell out of me for you but they did make
me take vocal class so I'm super
grateful for that because I got vocal
training like I don't even know help
with the stand-up just like using your
voice properly I know all of this stuff
like acting classes improv and all these
things like it we this is a tool that we
have to like you know chisel and like
our be like way better and I'm just like
super grateful for that and I got like
things secret life of pets too is
getting ready to come out right I was
gonna say I thought I wasn't sure if
that one had already come out but that's
again you Kevin Hart yeah bunch of
people and then I got the last og is
coming back in April that's the old you
you suck it on that I don't know you
know okay hey speak on it if you I mean
if you know you preferred let me I never
did this do it like this do you prefer
movies over the television or if you
were gonna do television you would want
it to be it should say the Tiffany had a
show and you know you're writing they're
producing it or you just prefer movies I
like stand-up comedy
I prefer stand-up comedy Oh interesting
I prefer to stand up comedy because it's
like immediate gratification and it's
what I wrote in how I want to do it like
so maybe I'm a little bit of a control
freak
but I do enjoy working with others and
like I love working with super creative
people and being able to make something
really fun and funny or really dramatic
and like heart-wrenching in like
collaborating
love that further immediate
gratification of like my ideas then
maybe I'm narcissistic in that way yeah
I get it though because it would be like
if we're doing a stand that we wouldn't
want to be doing standing but then in
the middle of a joke somebody goes cat
and then two riders come over can you
can you do it like that's the hard part
like in the middle of like okay we
talked about the scene you know what we
want to do we know how it's gonna go
everything and then you're doing it and
in a middle of like that creative life
creative flow yeah they're like cut hold
up lights
yeah yeah there's a problem something
completely out of your control
yeah I hate feeling like I'm in the
middle of a good take I hate feeling
like oh I'm nailing this but then you
know what yeah these are things that
come on your mind though to that like
let's say it's like let's say if we're
doing this is a scene and they got a
camera here or even like how we're doing
this like the camera might not even be
on like the cameras on me right now but
you might be doing a thing and they
missed it right you know or then you
realize that we're doing your coverage
right now right what should I give it
you know yeah I always give it 110
percent even if it's fun like if it's
your coverage right now and I'm doing
this thing with you I'm still gonna act
like read it on me but that works for
you I know but what I'm saying is
sometimes I hate when I'm doing that and
they be like but that's what you learn I
think what you learned is that you have
to pick and choose your moments to shine
because because it's not first is so
exhausting yeah now I've learned yeah
man but do I want to give like I just
feel like I was in the desert I really
got to drive but I just I hate that part
when I say cut and it's not time to cut
yeah okay I get to control freak part of
it I get the idea of like I that's why I
love doing stand-up for that same musics
because if it's bad it's on me it's all
you like I never even blame the crowd
you even have to
Crouch it II I just go okay I didn't
connect with these people Smythe with
this with my scene partner right now I
didn't connect with them so that's on me
but it is weird when you're like you
know you're doing something and you have
to deal with like like people don't
understand what um what a monster asset
is like how many moving parts and if
people are talking in the background and
Stephanie like ah you're like doing your
scene and you hear people talking you
know this is gonna have to be done over
because if I can hear them the camera
can write the law are you about to do a
really good scene and here comes that
you know the left of the plane they're
like hold for hold for plane you know
you're like these [ __ ] you know
so it is like a it is a different it's
like it's different it's like but you
have love for it I love it I love it I
love the actual like when it's happening
I hate the cut off like it's like having
sex in in somebody's like I'm not even
your [ __ ] mom like on my do it yeah
but that's what we get paid for exactly
that's what you get paid for and you
bring it that same energy again you know
it's almost like when people say they
want like when people go hey okay tip
you bring me to set and then in your
mind you're thinking yourself you don't
want to go to set no you're gonna be
doing it's favorable you're gonna be
bored as [ __ ]
you know I brought my friends they're
like this is what you do I realize it
looks like way more fun when you like on
the axis yeah this is the worse they are
really [ __ ] running you into the
ground right they're like yeah you're
like nah I'm not ready to this is the
process this is the way it goes like I
couldn't do it
this is uh no it i target thereby always
I know what's gonna happen so I go okay
yeah come yeah yeah yeah yeah be like
we're gonna hang out in my trailer and
watch TV
yeah yeah yeah that's about it cuz we're
gonna do this same line I guess seven
more times with six more setups the
cameras gonna get this angle just saying
okay so you're turning and then to turn
around so that's gonna be our
there's important that they get the back
part of my I don't know as they gotta
get this part some front part okay so
you got the real oh geez coming back
that's back coming back real let the
last oh gee the last oh gee you coming
out with that and then I got a cartoon
coming out because you're both cartoons
are coming out now I got another cartoon
is coming on Netflix car sweet yeah car
two can party that I deal with ally wand
oh that's great all right love ally
so that's come in and then and they
don't you produce in a show for she was
on him down appear yeah yeah we're
working on that was oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah we're working on that that's great
HBO and I by the way I want to say like
I want to say this the people don't know
about you is like when I heard that you
know cuz she was on said she was like
yeah I hadn't even met Tiffany and you
know whatever happened I don't know how
that came about but you were like yeah I
want to help you know you you're very
much like reaching down and trying to
pull people up exactly I'm doing unto
others as I would want them to do to me
yeah and like not the way that even came
about is her agent is Gerard's agent oh
and like we're cool so then I was like
talking to her she's like you should
come over here and I'm like man I like
it where I'm at but if you have any
clients that got anything going on and I
could work with I would love to work
with any of your clients like I really
like the people you represent and then
she told me about sotius project and I
said oh man that sounds great let me
talk to so she let me meet it and boom
and boom yeah that's great by the way
NBC reminds me of the Oklahoma Oklahoma
City Thunder you know they had Kevin
Durant they had you know James Harden
and they had Russell Westbrook and they
decided to trade those people away so
why the [ __ ] would you cancel now you
got a little rel out here killing it we
got 70 ashes I had a shot here killing
it and y'all were on the same show on
NBC right like that just seems really
stupid well I wouldn't say that
mperatures maybe maybe they just didn't
really look at the the possibilities or
maybe that's why supposed to happen so
that we could be where we are I know and
with the group maybe they couldn't
afford us nope up with them whatever it
is I think I just somebody somewhere out
there regretting
you know they got to be active
regretting it okay so you got the
cartoons you got and then what about
other live-action movies what's going on
there
yeah we got some more of those coming
out I got one with Melissa McCarthy come
in yes listen Amy I don't care what
she's in I'll watch it
she's amazing she just said no but she
just like like she's like Charlie
Chaplin like just funny you know me just
everything like her movement but did you
see our latest movie that wasn't it
wasn't a comedy yeah that this has
happened twice no did you see Tammy yes
same thing they they they they promoted
it like it was like a rom-com you know
but it was actually very tender but she
still has one of my funniest moments and
Tammy is like she's with the cops and
she tries to run away and they're
looking at her like what are you doing
he grabbed me she was like there was a
be just those little moments that she
does Oh dedicated to her characters like
she really is the kid like she plays the
character fully through like and it's
not to be funny it's to like deliver
this person's life and that's funny she
is that's what she is yeah but she is
she is portraying someone's life in
their in his planning moments in that
right right and that's what she she's
not trying to be funny or purposely like
oh this I'll be hell there why right
right so I'm gonna do this dismiss she's
just living that bad life in front of
the camera I said you being treated how
was that I mean with you guys he have a
lot of scenes with her yeah it was me
her Elizabeth mozz oh wow that's great
and it's not a comedy oh wow you excited
about that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's really good I just saw that
movie I just thought in its I was
shocked I could tell you look at you how
excited you are about it you're just
like I was an actress yeah well I was
like I'm like I'm gangster like just
like when I was lucky on him for the
first time I'm so glad you brought that
up
I was shocked I took when I remember I
told you my favorite parts of that were
like when you when you found out you
were a cop and those tender moments she
would have with him I was like that's
gonna be your thing you're gonna be
doing that you know I was shocked I was
like I was like you glad I knew I knew I
could do it but it's just like when you
see it I say wow that's me
yeah I know you know what I don't you
saying it was the same thing when I did
I'm dying up here yeah no this is a
dramatic show and I was so nervous about
it and all that but then when I saw it I
was like I was watching it like I don't
know who that is right and it helped me
because I had a wig on another kinda
stuff you know so you see but I like you
watching you go I I didn't realize that
just as possible not I mean so that's
what you're going through right now
right now I know it's possible it's just
like damn I'm beautiful do you love
seeing yourself on other big screen now
I mean why not cuz you could hate seeing
myself because you're like oh my God my
eyebrows like oh yeah I'm like that damn
eyebrow look at that pimple right here
cheap it's funny because the guy no guy
is looking at that like
yeah but I'm looking at the pimples I'm
like that my period started that so you
can't even enjoy so you got that movie
what else um there's more movies alright
that's great yeah there's a lot of
movies coming and it's basically gonna
be one coming out I think every or
something coming out every other month
so like six projects
that's credibly coming out this year and
then I'll be like more next I mean 10
years ago you know living in a car bro
no no no ten years ago no I was no I was
not
ten years ago now I was living in car I
don't think your thoughts yeah calling
you and you telling me girl that was
them I don't know why you did that I
don't know don't even give me I don't
know why uh okay it just doesn't make
any sense
so what so there's no dating going on
you don't have time for it no time I
want today I'm gonna ask everyone want
to but it's the last date that I went on
I fell asleep
damn what whoa okay whoa why was it
because it was too late at night no it
was the guy that boring what was he
talking about that made you fall asleep
have no idea what was it like at dinner
and I just the white guy no it was just
like wow like I couldn't hear I was so
exhausted I'm like he didn't pick up on
that that's terrible he's like TIFF I'm
telling you my business idea so was here
a second there was no second date mm-hmm
that's too bad yeah that's not it
doesn't count
oh yeah we like I don't need to know
about the booty calls and stuff I mean
one guy went to a wine tasting thing
with and that was fun but I kept falling
asleep on the bus I mean we can fall
asleep everywhere why do you go on dates
when you tired cuz there's no other time
oh my god because what I'm not tired I'm
working so you see they're sleep you're
sleeping working sleeping sleeping and
then you mix in a time before sleeping
to go on a date I tried mmm and I'm
sleeping during the day with the plane
so then this is why okay so if you want
a date Tiffany what you have to do is
take you something adventurous or
something like where you we have to like
do some stuff gotta be v gotta be like
doing something and when
I'd like to do a lot of things like I
like snowboarding I'm a fan or it's like
writing something I like I like to do a
lot of things but sometimes those things
I can't do because contractually I might
get hurt and then I came in here like a
professional athlete
yeah I can't some things I can't do
while I'm working on a project yeah you
can't be in a movie out surfing and
break your arm
exactly I don't even want it that's all
anything yeah you may not because I
insurance purposes
oh you got to be careful else you get
where the last time you surfed anyway
last year nope
the year before last year and where'd
you go did you go we on vacation oh
right here and Santa Monica oh you would
you surfed in Santa Monica yeah any
Malibu Wow
I missed it Huntington Beach - I would
love to see that'd be great you in a
movie with yours I want to be the black
Ballentine yeah that was a jam show it
was Sally Fields that was one of my
favor me too I love I still sometimes it
comes on and I loved that sure I loved
all those shows all times by myself like
which yeah I Dream of Jeannie yeah yeah
yeah did you like just sucking my thumb
just falling in
yeah those those are the good that was a
good old days those are the things that
I would maybe want to do this yeah who
was your main influence then like when
you were when you wanted to be a comic
who was that person you were like oh I
want to be like that or that is what I
want to do Carol Burnett and Lucille
Ball like watching them I'm like I
wanted I want to do it like I hadn't
seen no black woman do nothing like that
it's like maybe Kim Wayans on the Living
Colour but like I'm like I want to do
that black boy black I like that I like
that and then and that but then while at
the same time going through all the
things you were going through like
living in a group home having your mom
being crazy and you know I used to but
like you know what it's like it's just a
testament that like it can be done yeah
you know it can be they came to dad it
doesn't matter where you come from like
you can come from the bottom of the damn
barrel if you believe in yourself and
you put in the work
like every day you do something towards
whatever the goal is create a goal like
which I've surpassed oh my God look at
that keep making new ones like every
week cause it's like a tackle I'm like
oh good for you then you maybe need to
start like think of something lofty no
see that's where you can see that's
where you start to get disappointed so
what are your goals they give you know
my girls the SMAW girls by various
finish another movie Schiphol goes okay
like at first my girls used to be like
just okay just get on stage every night
I got you
then I would get on stage every night
then it's like okay right thirty minutes
worth of material yeah alright do that
like in two days easy
okay now book a TV shows they say if you
can make more money to a standard book a
TV shuts up book a TV show okay
book the TV show all right now okay so
they say oh if you act better you can
get a movie in if you get the right
movie you get more acting gig more
exposure exposure so then I put more
acid the seats you can perform a bigger
videos you can make more money doing
what you really want to do and that
stand-up okay okay so let me get a
little movie just any kind of little
movie someday but make sure the role is
something that resonates with me that
makes me feel good like and then boom
there goes
Keanu then it's like oh man okay now I
want to do a bigger movie I want to work
with like bigger people and maybe make a
little more money making a movie and
then I'm gonna do something really fun I
wanna do something fun something is
right trip here comes girls trip and
then like God yeah you wanted to do a
special special there's a special like
if there's this and they're like so
everything's like it kind of just but I
always kept it small like very
attainable you're very authentic to I
which I like that's why I'm really glad
to Groupon jumped on you because they
don't know that like before Groupon you
were yeah you have your group can't give
some Groupon sponsorship for this damn
no but you like you were very much like
you know you I remember you chased I'm
going on a group on vacation and you
were like everything's gonna be group
like it wasn't even about like getting
Ally you guys like
garlic's genuinely excited about like I
remember when Kazakh along the DUI and I
was like man it was like four other
comics got DUIs I was like I got to do
something about this I don't want to get
a DUI too because I do like to drink
it's let in that's how Groupon had
breathalyzers and that and I bought one
off there and it worked
I'll Groupon like we should go show us
our Groupon breathalyzer
it works so good right I've been pulled
over by the police like I blow into it
and as long as I blow believe below the
limit right it works so damn good when I
bought this it was $9.99 and I blows it
to it every time after I have a drink to
see where I met where my levels are it
is amazing that's very responsible is
right and if it blow if I blow too high
then I just sit my ass down
they need like that that'd be great if
you could blow into something like that
and it could tell you like if somebody
got like you know harpy yeah by the way
yep full circle yeah make sure you have
a rich spirit rich soul let me see where
we're at where we at man good credit
score
oh that's Wow look at that yeah you see
that all right but yeah these are now
$20 on Groupon and you got a 99 I got a
999 now they're $20 and it works
amazingly and I don't have a DUI to this
day go for you have you had a DUI before
that never okay good for you
no I'm drunk so you know I'm never gonna
get a deal why don't you drink I just
don't I just never had you know I I okay
when I was in high school I was at a
party and you were drinking no I tried
it so I like it was like a beer mm-hmm
and I tasted it and out you know like
trying to be cool uh you know you know
it was just nasty right I didn't like
you so then like and then I was hanging
around with these people that did drink
and I saw what was happening to them and
I was like I can't be like this
because I wanted I need to have my
faculties like optimum at all times I
said I even as a kid I was like that so
then I just never did it cuz I was like
I don't want to be like that I just
thought because in my mind I thought you
take a couple of sips and then that's it
you're gone you know I know it's not
like that I know that now
yeah that's a time I didn't know that
right so I was like I don't even want to
try so then the 2000 New Year's came you
know and it was like Armageddon
everybody thought they had keepall still
got people still got canned foods and
they you know you know and so I was at a
wild ass 1999 going into 2000 New Year's
party and the way I had to take care of
people at that party at the end of it at
the end of it I'm talking about my
friends in the bathtub
vomit I had to turn him somebody had a
baby I was taking care of a baby and
that was the moment that moment I
thought I've made this choice not to
drink this far I'm out right I'm gonna
have you be my designated driver from
now on that's me too people always call
calling me like I don't know if they
want to go out with me or they didn't
want me to drive what you doing tonight
you still got that big SUV cuz me and my
girls were you know I like but I don't
know I went on vacation with a buddy of
mine recently like a couple years ago
the first time I went on vacation
and you had to go on vacation now that
you famous yeah I keep telling you this
you got to go on vacation cause it's
important because we work so much you
got to take time for yourself but I said
that i'ma go on this vacation and I'm a
drink i'ma have like a real so I had
some champagne on the plane and I was
like okay this isn't bad then I had a
banana daiquiri yeah okay well I don't
I like shakes you know like I thought
the alcohol ruined it but this is was it
the bar had special drinks I just Resort
and there's a drink of the day and I
said I would try to drink it a day
I got like this much of it and I was
like I was like nope don't like this you
know to me I couldn't enjoy my food I
was like nah this ain't for me
so that's cuz you know it's like a
little bit is poisoning yourself thank
you
this is what I'm saying yeah that's why
I become deaf we can't see that good
yeah you put on extra weight I don't
need any more extra weight right so
that's why that's why I don't drink now
before I pull out this vac I know a
little flask you know which I got on
Groupon is man tears all right now I
want to finish with I know you want to
open up a youth center right and and and
that that's that's the real full circle
is that you want to make sure that
people that were in your experience
don't they don't have it as hard as you
had it right well I just want to make
sure that there is a place where you can
be creative you know and they're taking
a lot of that out of schools now they're
sure dramas there's some music that's on
this and I want to create a place where
you can where as a child you can be
creative you know and adults can share
what they know and like I think that's
super important right now I got my
foundation she ready foundation she
ready foundation yes she ready
foundation and with that I'm just like
right now we're just I was just you know
as a kid as a former foster you can be a
move from house to house the house in
like all my clothes being a trash bags I
felt like garbage being moved around so
what I'm doing now is like I'm raising
money I take a lot of money for my
comedy shows and like if I take pictures
with people like I don't keep that money
the picture money I take that money and
I'll go buy suitcases for for youth or
whatever that foster youth and make sure
they have a suitcase so when they're
traveling from house to house they don't
feel like garbage being moved around
they feel like a traveller original
thing if it makes you feel the
confidence I remember when I got my
first suitcase how I felt like oh wow
I'm on an adventure now like I'm not
just a bag of honor a whole board is
garbage being put in this person's house
or that person stuff like now I'm a
visitor yeah you know I'm moving on to
something are you going I could fold my
[ __ ] in like yeah and it's in my bag
this belongs to me this is mine
right because you don't have like a lot
of times you don't get to have it
sometimes I just take you out of a home
you don't get to take
your clothes you just have to close on
your back like so it's it's really since
having something like that it can really
change a person's mind from the way they
think of themselves you know and I want
to be and I remember being that kid and
saying like if I ever get any power I'm
gonna try to make sure no other kids
feel like this I try my best to keep you
know I'm not gonna here help everybody
or heal everybody like I'm I'm not gonna
have that part that's like kind of
impossible but if I can help some people
30 40 100 200 feel better about
themselves then I think I did something
good Tiffany that is great you mean you
really are an inspiration
you really are for line not just not
just and by the way not just women an
inspiration for everyone you know coming
up from hugly you did and shout out to
comedy camp Jamie Masada over at the
Laugh Factory so he doesn't like you
know I really appreciate you coming on I
appreciate you I appreciate our
friendship I'm so glad that everything
that's happened in your life and it's
only gonna get better and you know if
you people want to donate to the she
ready foundation or you know yandex
gotta she ready foundation that work she
ready foundation org I'm gonna have all
this information on the phone down below
guys it's all the informations down
below and thank you for coming on you
know I love you so much I love you too
alright and we're gonna talk in a friend
way hi IBG places me too yeah be with
you gonna like Bermuda or Papa yet say
but I miss how vision I'll and I need to
go to a place though that they are okay
with somebody big being on the sling
thing like I said the Polynesian
good appreciated but anyway this has
been Tiffany Haddish and I'm Eric
Griffin thank you for watching another
episode of referent with Griffin and
I'll see you guys next week yeah
[Music]